é oque é
nós estamos no ano 2045 recentemente o
matemático Russo aleksei novikov ganhou
um milhão de dólares ao resolver um dos
problemas do milênio mais importantes o
problema P versus NP eles responsável
por conceber um algoritmo cérebros capaz
de transformar problemas difíceis em
problemas fáceis de resolver de repente
o cancro deixou de ser uma preocupação
que já lá vão os tempos da quimio e
radioterapia e o cabelo rapado
atualmente o problema fica resolvido
levando uma farmácia uma pena USB com a
classificação das proteínas adequadas ao
doente que permitem combater as células
cancerígenas se
e também já ninguém marca batizados em
dias de chuva graças ao algoritmo
cérebros nós somos capazes de prever com
exatidão absurda os fenômenos
meteorológicos incluindo tempestades e
tornados e furacões o que permite
elaborar planos de evacuação com
antecedência e salvar milhares de vidas
é surpreendente mente até a criatividade
passou a ser automatizada ou analisar
milhões de obras de arte êxitos musicais
e romances de sucesso os computadores
são agora capazes de produzir arte
adequada aos interesses e preferências
de cada um de nós vocês vão a Amazônia e
encomenda um romance a vossa medida nós
fomos abençoados pelo algoritmo cérebros
e vivemos mesmo num Admirável Mundo Novo
outra isto apenas uma Utopia regressando
a2021 quem é que nesta sala a isso aqui
se poderá tornar uma realidade
Ah tá então mais ou menos otimistas hoje
mais ou menos bem para responder esta
pergunta precisamos de compreender
melhor em que consiste este misterioso
problema P versus NP PE
e a pergunta Será que pena = NP
prende-se com a dificuldade de resolver
problemas Pois tanto o p como NP são
duas classes de problemas então uma
forma extremamente simplificada a classe
de problemas P consiste no problemas que
nós conseguimos resolver de forma
eficiente utilizando um computador e não
esqueçam os problemas fáceis já a classe
de problemas NP consiste nos problemas
que possuem uma solução facilmente
verificável utilizando o computador e
agora novo possamos não ter nenhum
método rápido e viável para encontrar
são os problemas potencialmente difíceis
mas precisamente encontram-se em Pedro
os problemas cuja solução nós
conseguimos mesmo encontrar de uma forma
rápida já entendi que são problemas que
nós podemos não conseguir solucionar de
forma rápida mas
é um extraterrestre aparecer a terra com
uma solução correta para um problema em
IP nos conseguimos verificar rapidamente
que essa solução terá que essa solução
está correta Ok mesmos estão de máscara
e eu estou a perceber vocês não haviam
umas caras um bocado estranhas por isso
deixem-me dar-vos um exemplo assim de
grosso modo um problema de encontrar uma
agulha num palheiro é um problema que
está na classe NP porque é muito difícil
nos encontrarmos o raio de uma agulha no
palheiro mas se não se tivermos num
palheiro e alguém disser está aqui a
agulha encontrei a é fácil nós
verificarmos que a pessoa resolver um
problema porque ela tem a agulha na mão
e assim dizer q p = NP é o mesmo que nós
dizemos que conseguimos resolver
rapidamente todos os problemas cuja
solução conseguimos verificar
rapidamente estamos basicamente a dizer
que é tão fácil verificar que a solução
disso o custo a correta como resolver os
o clube raiz O que é letramento
contra-intuitivo uma coisa é nós olhamos
para aqui e verificarmos que em cada
linha e em cada coluna surgem os números
de 1 a 9 sem violar as regras outra
coisa é nós conseguirmos preencer a
grelha de raiz que seria abortivas é
bastante mais complicado de facto a
maior parte dos peritos na área um grupo
de pessoas no Cola não inclui de todo
acredita que é diferente de NP que há
problemas que são mesmo difíceis no
entanto a questão que será que te = NP
permanece em aberto neste momento
ninguém sabe e quem resolver habilita si
mesmo a ganhar
o nome de Dólares nos estamos muito
longe continuamos completamente às
escuras no que diz respeito a encontrar
uma prova formal para este dilema tudo o
que há são intuições e palpites pode
acontecer que pensa seja Igualmente e
nesse caso nós vivemos naquele
maravilhoso mundo que eu te escrevi
inicialmente mas mesmo provar que é
diferente teria grandes implicações
sobre a forma como nós abordamos
problemas Além disso dentro da classe de
problemas NP Existem os problemas muito
especiais chamados problemas
np-completos A ideia é que uma solução
eficiente para um problema np-completo
pode ser transformada numa solução
eficiente para qualquer problema em NP
logo resolver um único problema
np-completo de uma forma eficiente
permite-nos saber te dá para resolver
todos os problemas em MP de uma forma
eficiente e assim demonstrar que ter eh
eh
o que fazer a maior festa das nossas
vidas um exemplo de um problema
np-completo é decidir se uma Instância
do jogo Mini sweepers admite solução
permitirmos Campos minados para evitar e
a mente grandes logo resolver uma isso
hiper eficientemente poderá conduzir-nos
a uma cura para o cancro
e vale a pena pensar nisto na pronto
então por tudo isto a muitas pessoas que
consideram que o problema P versus NP é
o problema mais importante da Matemática
logo é fundamental nos criar os
ferramentas que nos permitam estudar
forma sistemática métodos eficientes de
resolução de problemas e isso leva-nos a
área das ciências da computação mas o
que é que é computação mesmo computação
não é trabalhar com tecnologia a fazer
PowerPoint sou reparar impressoras já
dizia o grande é de vai mostrar o
Cientista da Computação não quer saber
da tecnologia específica utilizada na
concretização física de uma máquina seja
ela electrónica óptica pneumática ou
magia
da Computação computação é tentar
perceber porque é que alguns problemas
são difíceis e outros são fáceis ao
analisar a sua estrutura matemática
computação é tentar capturar a
complexidade do mundo natural de uma
forma algorítmica é pensarmos sobre os
fenómenos que nos rodeiam de uma forma
tão Clara e metódica que somos capazes
de transmitir luz a um computador uma
aglomeração de componentes físicas
Desprovida de intelecto mas atenção
habitualmente nós temos uma ideia muito
redutor daquilo que é um computador em
geral um computador é tudo aquilo que
recebe armazena processa e devolve
informação aliás vocês sabiam que os
fungos basidiomicetos podem ser
utilizados como computadores em um só
espetáculo o micélio do Fungo fornece
uma rede de processadores e o Brasil Car
é utilizado como uma rede de
input-output daqui a pouco até a micose
que tem no pé um computador Queres ver
aí Siri Abra o YouTube dela toda esta
abrangência da área das ciências da
computação e o papel importante que
desempenha na solução de problemas de
variadíssimas outras áreas eu considero
a que seria benéfico estimular o
pensamento computacional desde tenra
idade instituiu o mesmo como prática
pedagógica sendo hoje estão o bico as
tecnologias baseadas na computação de
que as pessoas dependem e utilizam nos
mais variados setores da sua vida social
e profissional se na aceitável que a
maior parte das pessoas não tenha sequer
a mínima ideia do que está por trás tudo
isso vai estar a confiar mos numa Elite
de técnicos superespecializados que tudo
fazem e em que todos Confiam
se por um lado que pensar
computacionalmente permite-nos
estruturar o pensamento de forma a
resolver problemas e expressar as suas
soluções de uma forma Clara e eficiente
por outro lado é inegável o papel que a
tecnologia desempenha nas nossas vidas
isso é daquelas coisas que eu nem sequer
tem nos forçar para argumentar Tipo olha
a tua volta meu
e nós já não vivemos num mundo em que
uma lei proíbe a posse de armas nós
vivemos num mundo em que uma lei proíbe
a posse de armas bem como a posse de
ficheiros digitais que possam ser
utilizados para criar armas através de
impressoras 3D às tantas no futuro vai
ser legal uma pessoa sequer pensar no
conceito de arma não vai inventar em
outros requisitos um dispositivo
qualquer capaz de materializar os nossos
pensamentos
e agora convidar vamos assim a pensar
comigo um bocadinho sim espaço na escola
para aprender que Frederico segundo foi
imperador do sacro Império
romano-germânico em 1221 canismo
tensão-coesão-adesão no transporte da
seiva bruta nas plantas também tem de
haver espaço para a computação uma
disciplina transversal a todas as áreas
do conhecimento o sim dias a áreas de
estudo como biologia computacional
química computacional Psicologia
computacional de fisiologia
computacional linguística computacional
juro eu não estou a inventar só vem
aquela Malta que não secundário vai para
humanidade Só mesmo para fugir ao
matemática daquela relação à vontade e
depois vem de computação ninguém
consegue escapar
e felizmente de alguns países que deram
um passo na direção do Futuro
implementados nas escolas uma disciplina
obrigatória de computação a partir de
certo. Trata-se de uma oportunidade
única para causar impacto na inclusão e
sucesso de novas gerações EA evidência
científica que apoia o ensino das
ciências da computação e não só da
programação esse o que é algo mais
limitador
é mas pronto a todos sabendo que
Portugal costuma estar assim um
bocadinho atrasado relativamente aos
outros países ao mesmo tempo que o avião
supersônico Concorde fazer o seu
primeiro voo em São Martinho de candoso
onde os meus pais viviam o principal
meio de transporte era o carro de bois
eu eu acho mesmo aqui na minha modesta e
provavelmente irrelevante opinião está
na altura de nos mudarmos de paradigma
Ok e caminharemos juntos em direção ao
futuro Seguindo os passos da Inglaterra
dos Estados Unidos e Israel nova Nova
Zelândia ou Rússia implementando o
ensino da Computação nas escolas agora
vou contar um segredo já existe em
Portugal uma associação dedicada esta
causa fundada por um maravilhoso ser
humano chamado Luiz Neves e da coleção
Embaixadora
só este ano já nos encontramos em três
escolas do país a numa fase piloto e
estamos ensinar Ciências da Computação a
várias turmas desde o 5º ao 8º ano
eu não vou consigo descrever o
entusiasmo e o brilho nos olhos dos
alunos quando nós dizer explicamos o
funcionamento dos códigos QR o sistema
binário ou a representação de imagens e
vídeos no computador eles atende
perguntou-se para o ano vão continuar a
ter computação e Olhem que nós
utilizamos um método muito pouco
convencional ou se calhar não nós temos
ensinado tudo apenas com Lápis e Papel
porque acreditamos que é fundamental
primeiro que eles percebam as ideias
base do pensamento computacional antes
de meterem as mãos na massa e se
aventurarem a programar um computador e
ele diz Imaginem as aulas são que 45 50
minutos não saber como é que são as
escolas computadores da escola os
primeiros 15 minutos em para tentar por
computadores a trabalhar mas depois
aquela ficha que não encaixa ali e
aquele Não tenho ouro e não sei que
nascemos perder a Leão inteiro Então
olha foi pelo v
um lápis e papel e tem funcionado que é
que eu fiz a tempestade muito bem ok
digam-me lá se não era um espetáculo o
problema P versus NP ser resolvido por
um Manuela uma Joaquina e merecer um ano
se o índio ou uma Dominica pavlova um
pessoal não era canção a canção pessoal
eu tenho muito orgulho no Cristiano
Ronaldo e no facto de termos fabricado o
maior pão com chouriço do mundo mas se
calhar não fazia mal investir noutras
áreas e
e eu acredito profundamente que este é
um momento e a oportunidade de promover
a literacia e ética digital dotando Os
estudantes de um pensamento
crítico-analítico e computacional que os
ajudará a resolver problemas no dia a
dia todos os jovens do Século 21
deveriam ter a oportunidade de aprender
sobre algoritmos Como criar páginas web
e aplicações ou sobre como funciona a
internet assim como aprendem sobre
fotossíntese Como funciona o sistema
digestivo eletricidade química ou
álgebra a computação é um portal para o
futuro e se atuarmos agora talvez ainda
o consigamos atravessar sem pagar
bilhete muito obrigada pela vossa
atenção e